We're so excited to have
20 here hear from Austin. Um, I think
most of you know her. Um, for her,
she has fought tirelessly, uh, first
as a Texas state senator and then, um,
and her run for governor, uh, Fort
Women's reproductive rights, uh,
gender equal pay,
Lgbtq rights,
justice for sexual assault survivors
just has an incredible track record.
Um, and I think you probably also know
her for a somewhat historic 13 hour
filibuster in some cases,
sneakers.
MMM.
And most recently she has started an
advocacy group called deeds, not words,
which we're going to talk about today.
That is all about channeling the energy
and passion for gender equality into
actionable change. So hello everyone.
Okay.
So why don't we start with deeds,
not words and tell us a little bit
about it and why you founded it. I
started deeds, not words. It's a
nonprofit organization about a year ago.
It really starting from the perspective
of wanting to make sure that we were
giving the best opportunity for that
next generation of young women who are
going to be the filibuster errors of the
future to find their way to that path.
Um,
I travel and speak a lot and I was
frequently asked a question that I'm still
asked a lot, which is
what do we do right? And,
and you see this incredible
knowledge and passion,
but sometimes a struggle about where to
connect that to action. And so deeds,
not words was born really
with two big ideas in mind.
One is to make sure that we're putting
together in one place an area that you
can go to a hub,
our digital hub,
and you can find a variety of different
organizations and the work that they're
doing in the gender equality world.
And it's separated by health.
So things that are happening in the
reproductive rights world. For example,
safety, which of course
includes campus sexual assault,
human trafficking and sexual assault,
criminal justice reform work.
Um,
economic opportunity,
which includes a lot of organizations
that are working on equality of pay on
affordable quality,
child care,
on increasing the minimum
wage on family leave policies.
All of those things that make such an
important difference in our ability to
equalize our economic
opportunity in this country.
And then leadership,
there are so many different organizations
who have one based right here in
California emerge that are really there
for women to make sure that where we
have women who are thinking about
stepping forward and running for office,
they have the support around and the
system that helps them to raise money and
to have the resources and the knowledge
that they need to do that and to do it
well.
So that's what we do in the digital space.
We have a weekly digital
newsletter called the deeds digest.
And in that newsletter we inform,
we try to inspire,
I hope we do sometimes and we end each
deeds digest with the dues of the week.
And those dues always tie in to the
things that we talked about in that
particular newsletter.
And then we do a daily deed.
We started doing that just a few
weeks ago, um, post women's march,
trying to make sure that where people
were looking for a way to plug in and some
direction and guidance in that regard.
We do that.
That's all the digital part of what we do.
The other piece of it,
and certainly this is how I found
my way into the political world,
is helping us to find
our power as advocates.
It can be kind of hard to navigate your
way into that and to know exactly how to
do it.
I think that indivisible has been such
an important resource and helping people
to see how we can use our voices
in a very, very powerful way.
And I love the structure and the guidance
that they've put together for that.
We are doing tactical
trainings of advocacy work.
So we started in Texas.
We have our eye on several other
states that we want to expand into,
but we're working with both high
school and college age, young women.
And we're helping to foster their
voices into the legislative process.
So they're working on two key issues
right now with a number of legislators,
kind of from idea to how you write a piece
of legislation to coming to committee
hearings and testifying for it and how
you present yourself and how to make a
most effective argument.
And the areas that we're really focusing
on in that work are sex trafficking of
minors and also sexual assault reforms
in both the criminal justice world rape
kit backlog, for example,
statute of limitations issues,
but also campus sexual assault and kind
of changing the landscape of what our
understanding is about consent.
Um, how we define that,
how we define um, yes, rather
than no means no. What,
what does it mean to say
yes. Um, so we're focused on,
on those things and we find that our
young audience is very interested and
passionate about those particular issues.
And so it's been a really good way
to foster their advocacy skills.
What's been the most surprising thing
that you've discovered since starting?
I guess just the,
the challenge of taking an idea.
I can do the political thing pretty well.
I know how to navigate my way in that.
And that's a learning curve too,
just like anything. But it's a
learning curve for me right now.
How to take these ideas and
most effectively implement
them and just how hard it
is to be a startup.
A startup nonprofit is no different really
than a startup profit other than you
obviously don't need to make money.
You need people to donate money to the
vcs are maybe a little less excited about
the nonprofit. Sorry. I guess
that's so true. Yeah. Um,
but I think most surprising is
just how eager people are to,
to be connected in ways that make them
feel like their voices really make a
difference and they do make a difference.
They truly do.
And what, and so it sounds
like from everything you're
talking about that to you,
the biggest way to
affect political change,
kind of the current political landscape.
Would it be to get more women out there?
Nope. Awesome. Um, what,
what else? Like what else?
Obviously you need to have your
focus on, on, on, on say, advocacy.
What other areas do you think could
be making a difference right now?
I'm sure there are a lot of people in
this room and on the livestream that want
to know how they could get more involved.
What do you think is the most effective?
You and I had a great conversation a
moment ago before we came up here and I
thought you actually characterize
and crystallize this perfectly.
What you were saying was that we have to
pick those two or three things that we
are really going to care about and dive
into and try to avoid the temptation
because there's so much
going on right now, um,
to weigh in an every little space.
So whatever that area
of passion is for you,
whether it's the environment or Lgbtq
equality or transgender rights and
specific or women's equality and
all of the different realms of that,
find the place that really connects
to you or that you connect to.
Because what you'll find, I've
certainly always found this in my life.
If you follow the thing that you really
care about and you use your energy on
that thing,
it's going to take you to a place that
you wouldn't have expected and it's going
to be unbelievably
fulfilling but personally,
but also with your ability to actually
have an impact on it because it's coming
from a place that's really true too.
So whatever that is,
look for organizations that are
working in that world. You know,
if it's voting rights,
you know, a Clu, um,
if it's a women's reproductive freedoms,
obviously you know,
the incredible organizational work of
groups like planned parenthood and Nay
Raul, but maybe you don't know so much
about the center for reproductive rights,
which is doing all the legal work
on this and actually were the,
the major impetus behind successful
supreme court case that we won last year.
Um,
maybe you care particularly about making
sure that women have access to safe and
legal abortion.
And you want to really get into the
ground level of that and support
organizations like the Lilith Fund,
which makes sure that women can afford
to have an abortion if they otherwise
don't have the financial means to do that.
So there's so many different ways to
plug in and what we hope to do with our
website and we're actually in a revamp
of it right now to make it much more
meaningful. If you're looking
for that place to plug in. Um,
we want to be a place where you can go
and depending on that area of interest,
you plug into one of those organizations
and you will find immediately two or
three key ways that they're asking for
you to get involved on a realtime basis,
some more intense and some less intense,
but ways where you can meaningfully be
contributing your time and your energy.
And what about companies?
What role do you think companies
should or shouldn't have?
Have you seen their advocacy be effective?
I think there are,
advocacy is tremendously effective.
Um,
I'm sensitive obviously to the
fact that companies walk, uh,
uh, quite a fine line in terms of not
wanting to get involved so much in the
partisan world.
And that makes sense because they have
consumers who sit on both sides of that
line. They have, I'm sure employees
that sit on both sides of that line.
But I think we find our way into the
things that make sense when we are being
very issue focused.
And so for example,
last year in my home state of Texas,
uh,
American Airlines became the title sponsor
of the planned parenthood luncheon in
Dallas for the very first time.
I almost cried. I literally,
I was so blown away by it because it
means such a powerful statement for a
company like that to say we support
women's reproductive healthcare and this
organization and in the face of all the
political flack that planned parenthood
is in the midst of, we're going to step
forward and we're going to do this.
So I think,
you know,
for companies to find their way into
issue areas that really mattered to them
and to use their influence. And there
are many ways for them to do that.
Of course,
we certainly saw the incredible impact
in North Carolina last year with the
transgender bathroom
bill, Texas, by the way.
It's trying to replicate that right now.
And I'm pleased to see we've got some
corporate push back already beginning to
percolate.
But that corporate push back in North
Carolina not only contributed to really,
um, uh, an economic impact to the state,
but it made such a powerful statement
economically that it impacted the way
voters thought about that issue.
So that in the last gubernatorial race
that they had during the presidential
election cycle, they elected
a statewide democrat. Um,
that was considered a really long
shot thing to do there actually.
And they did it because people,
now we're coming at this issue
from a variety of perspectives,
whether it was something that they cared
about from their social conscience or
whether they cared about
it because they understand,
understood it was having an impact
economically to their state and maybe to
their own book.
Uh,
that's what companies have
the power to do and to,
to broaden the conversation in a way
that really does lift it up out of the
social and makes it something that's
much more meaningful in the day to day
lives of people who have respect for or
who are impacted by the decisions and
the actions that that company takes.
So where do you think companies are
still being silent? Like why don't,
what issue do you wish companies
are speaking out more of that?
When I looked at what happened
in North Carolina, um,
with appreciation and awe
for the companies that
stepped forward so powerfully
on that and objected to it,
I found myself longing for that
same response in other areas.
Um,
I of course am very focused on gender
equality and I wish we saw more of that
when it came to issues that
particularly impact women in Texas.
When we pass that antiabortion bill in
2013 that was in and of itself terrible.
But what happened actually two years
prior to that that a lot of people didn't
know about,
there was no big filibuster.
It didn't capture the attention of people
around the world in 2011 in an assault
on planned parenthood,
there was a dramatic defunding of women's
health care there and they couldn't
really de-select just planned parenthood.
Um,
and so what happened was that there
was this wholesale withdrawal of funds.
Number one,
the state decided to no longer
participate in the women's health program,
which was giving us about $30 million
a year for women's reproductive health
care.
It's aimed particularly at lowering the
Medicaid birth rate and saving taxpayer
money by virtue of doing it.
And it really was saving a tremendous
amount of taxpayer money. Um,
we deep participated in that and that
affected not just planned parenthood,
but everyone that was getting
money for birth control,
reproductive healthcare
services in our state.
And then there was also a $78 million
state defunding of these women's
reproductive healthcare centers. None
of these were providing abortion care,
not a single one.
And overnight we had over 80
clinics close all over our state.
Those that still remained open.
We're hobbled really badly and could only
see a small percentage of the patients
that they'd been seeing.
And there's a wide range of estimates
about the number of women who were
impacted,
but it's anywhere from 100 to
180,000 women in one fell swoop.
And we see the circumstances
of that in our state.
We have the highest maternal death rate
of any developed country in the world.
In the state of Texas.
Our maternal death rate doubled in
about a six year period of time.
So these are dramatic,
horrific human consequences that women
are getting sucked into by virtue of
partisan politics. And I want to
see companies step forward and say,
when these sorts of things are happening,
you know,
we were going to relocate our corporate
headquarters to Dallas, Texas,
and now we've decided not to,
or were the NCA and we were going to
host the final four there and now we've
decided not to or were the
Superbowl and we were coming,
but now we're not going to,
I want to see that kind of response when
women are under assault because it's
not just that we are failing to
realize our full equal opportunity.
It's that we literally are the shrapnel
in these political wars where human
lives are being impacted
and devastating ways.
And it's something that we all ought to
care about because at the end of the day,
it impacts everyone. And at the end of
the day, it impacts our economy as well.
So how do you do it?
How do you get women into this obviously
disproportionately dramatically affects
the poor,
right?
And then you have a wealthier women
who are at companies who are at these
companies.
How do you get them to stand up in the
same way that people have stood up for
other rights, like rights for other groups
that they don't necessarily belong to?
I think part of it starts within
the culture of the organization,
the company itself.
Right. And what does the,
what is the makeup of that company look
like in terms of the number of women on
it's board,
the number of women that are in the
executive suites of that company.
That has a lot of influence
in these conversations. Um,
and so continuing for gender equality
in the positions that women occupy is a
very important part of that.
Josh says is the case for making sure
that we have women fully reflected at
every level of representative
government in this country unless,
and until we have that,
we're not going to move this
conversation really where it needs to go,
but we have an opportunity as employees
and as to to exert our own influences.
Uh, we've been talking about
that a bit at deeds, not words.
When I first was hatching this idea,
one of the things I wanted us ultimately
to be able to do is to weigh in as
consumers and to help direct consumer
decision making based on a company's score
with how well it's doing
to support gender equality.
Is this a company where there are,
um,
a representative number of women in the
executive suites and on the board is,
it's a company that's like salesforce
done a self examination of pay equity and
worked hard to make sure
they were equalizing.
It is that a company that has a good a
family leave policy both for dads and
moms so that we do have true gender
equality in the way that that's happening
and helping to drive people's positive
buying decisions based on companies that
score well in that regard.
Right now.
I'm sure you've all seen grab your
wallet and Grab Your Wallet is doing, uh,
I think an interesting job of making
sure that they're making people aware of
how to take their dollars
away as consumers from
companies who aren't behaving
well. I have found myself
responding to that. Um,
and, and thinking about which rideshare
company I'm going to use for example,
or, um, which retail establishment,
not Macy's that I'm going to shop at.
Um,
I have my unexperienced with Macy's
because they actually advocated against an
equal pay law in Texas and were successful
in getting the governor to veto an
equal pay law that I worked very,
very hard on.
So if any of your shopping at Macy's,
it's going to add my 2 cents to what's
already on the grab your wallet site when
it comes to that particular company.
But we have influences in that regard
and I think we're starting to see some of
the response that private companies are
making to watching the way consumers are
responding.
This young woman that we were talking
about earlier who just recently left Uber
and who shared her story essentially
for the outside world and the immediate
impact that that's had a while,
she worked within that culture for a
very long time trying to change it,
bringing outside attention
on it and having the,
the executive offices have to deal with
the public opinion of their company
based on that.
That experience,
I think it has shown
we have a lot of power.
If we can really kind of focus that you
had to think an acronym to see easier.
Right?
Right now it's very almost,
it's an entirely almost offline or an
individual experience where yes, Kay,
you can post
on social that you've done boycotted
something or support something.
But it'll be interesting to see how
that evolves is that I think the tech
solutions get easier with a company,
like you said,
the companies that are doing the things
that align with your values and how that
gets surfaced.
So how did you get into politics and
what was the moment where you were just
like, Oh wow, I'm a big deal.
I haven't had, I promise you I haven't
had that moment. I'm like, what?
That when you went to cabinet
or during a filibuster. Yeah. I,
I know we all do this,
but I think women particularly do this.
We take in all the things that we're not
achieving as opposed to celebrating the
things that we're doing well, right?
We tend to be very self critical. Um,
but my entree into politics and the
reason that I was really committed to the
advocacy training work of deeds,
not words happened when I went
to a city council meeting,
I was in my thirties.
I was arguing for something in my
neighborhood along with, you know,
a lot of other people in
the neighborhood community.
And I walked into that council chamber,
express my opinion and
then just got the idea,
well, I could be one of those
people sitting up there, you know,
and this is interesting actually,
and I think I would really
thrive in this environment.
And so it just opened up the idea for me.
I had not been paying
attention to politics.
I was one of those people that
I really work on right now. Um,
I was a young single mom.
I was working two jobs and going to school
and my struggles did not include the
thought about how my voice could make a
difference in the political world. And I,
I really didn't set up and pay attention
to it until I saw Hillary Clinton
fighting for universal health care as
first lady. That was kind of my first,
you know,
tug into it where it,
it seemed relevant and meaningful to
me based on my own experiences and
struggles with healthcare as an uninsured
person. So we find our ways. Again,
I think, um, when we are,
we're help to demystify that process
where we see that those fancy capitol
buildings,
whether we're talking about the one
in DC or the ones around our states,
those buildings belong to us.
There's nothing
really mysterious or,
or intimidating about them.
And I think we have to demystify them.
And,
and I'm pleased to be doing that for
some young people in my own state and
helping them to see that, you know,
the people that are elected there,
while they may refer to it
as my district or my office,
the district is actually one
that belongs to the people.
Our office belongs to us.
They have to at least at
some level listened to us,
even if they do avoid us in town halls,
which some of them around
the country have been doing,
but we the power to speak out by calling
their offices right in their offices,
coming to committee hearings and letting
them know how we feel about things.
And um,
I hope that the more people we
can encourage and to that venue,
the more young women will see that they
have every right to be sitting up at
those decision making tables and that
they'll begin to view that as something
that they want to do for themselves.
And you know,
I imagine one of the most discouraging
things when you're thinking about running
for any kind of office or speaking up
is that you always know that this is all
going to be seen through the lens of
your gender. And I remember, I mean,
I remember when you were running for
governor and there was like how many hours
a week did you spend with your kids?
Right?
Or it was like how many days
in a month when you were,
did you go back to see your kids, which
you never ever, ever, right, right.
What happen? Um, and it's got to be
something that's quite discouraging.
Not only just the public aspect of the
soul, but knowing that you're going to be,
you have to fight twice as hard
to be taken seriously. How,
you know, how did you navigate
that? I mean, was it, do you know,
to a certain degree you'd have to play
that game that you can't transcend it
entirely the same time you want to
have control over your narrative.
How did you to
approach that or how do you
purchase it today too? For me, it's,
it's still one of the most frustrating
experiences that I've had in the
political world and women
faced this and you know,
every level of profession.
One of the things that was successfully
done to me during my gubernatorial race,
and it was really kind of,
I mean,
if I stand aside and just
look at it as a spectator,
I'm rather fascinated by it
being in the middle of it.
It was horrific and painful.
Um,
but one of the clever things that happens
in the political world is trying to
figure out how to take a candidates
best asset and make it their weakness.
And that's what happened with me.
My asset was my story,
the American dream story of
coming from poverty, struggling,
fighting,
making my way all the way
through Harvard law school,
first person in my family to ever even
go to college, nevermind graduate.
And then to,
you know,
have a career where I gave back to my own
life experiences and the things that I
fought for that, that
was my feather, right?
That was the thing that I could
distinguish myself about. Well,
my story got ripped out from under me.
I was a bad mother.
I commuted back and forth from Boston to
Fort Worth and my second and third year
of law school because that first year,
taking my girls there with me,
what's not just really hard on me.
It was so hard on them.
Um, and where a man would never
have been questioned about that.
My Bona Fides as a mother
was called in to question.
My two daughters actually
had to come forward. And,
uh,
they wrote a very heartfelt letter that
they read publicly about my bonafide,
he's has a mother.
Um,
you just wouldn't see
this happening for men,
but I understood why they were doing it.
And I also understood with some of the
labels that they used with me why they
were doing them.
Abortion Barbie was a label that
was used quite often for me.
And in fact,
when I came to do some fundraising in
southern California during that race,
there were these big posters that
have been put up all over la with,
there were three d posters with
a Barbie plastic transparent,
uh,
belly with a plastic baby doll in the
belly and me with scissors in my hand.
Um, so why would they do that? Well,
a couple of things. Number one,
they wanted to make me a candidate that
was all about abortion and to take away
the entire body of work that I had done
as a public servant and what I had to
offer as a candidate.
But they also wanted the Barbie
image was very purposeful.
If we can invite voters to think about
women candidates in terms of how we look,
then we dismiss our capacities as leaders.
We're inviting people to think about
them as mothers and bad mothers at that.
Um,
as women who are no more than the makeup
of what we look like and to therefore
take away our perspectives
about our true value as leaders.
It happens to women in the
political world all the time.
I am not unique.
Uh,
it was particularly bad in my race and
it's particularly bad in Hillary's race,
but it happens to women all the
time. And I think, you know, the,
the best way to ride through that and
to rise above it is to continue to fight
back every single time and
to pop right back up. That,
that was one of the things that
I always admired about Hillary.
I've never seen anyone that could pop
right back up and get back out there and
fight another day. And it's
unfortunate that we have to do it,
but it's the reality.
And I think unless and until we have more
women in those gubernatorial mansions
and,
and until we have a woman in the White
House and we can show the incredible
capacity that women have to lead
in those executive positions,
we're going to continue to
struggle with these stereotypes.
So I really committed to just doing
everything we can to chip away at it and
school boards and city councils
and every state legislative,
um, body in this country and obviously
at the congressional and of course the
presidential level too.
And so you,
you've lost the race and you know,
in the valley we love to talk about
failure and it makes us all stronger.
And like there's usually a story, oh,
I failed at this and then I, you know,
it was bankrupt and I looked up at the
stars and realize that it disrupts the
auto industry or something. Right. And
then you become this like a millionaire.
Did you have an equivalent moment?
I mean,
did you take anything from that failure?
Most definitely.
I,
I wrote an essay for Lena
Dunham's Lenny letter,
um,
just within a few months of that race.
And if it's okay for
me to say a curse word,
the title of my essay was
I fucking hate to lose. Um,
and, and I talked about just what a
competitive person I am by nature.
I'm sure a lot of you are as well.
Um,
but that,
you know,
going back to that beautiful
Teddy Roosevelt, um,
quote about what it
means to be in the ring,
to be that person who sweats and tries
their hardest and comes up short,
but how much more glorious it is to be
that person than to be the person who's
standing on the sideline as the critic.
Right?
It's only when we
put ourselves out there and we risk
losing that we will ever move the ball.
Um,
there's value no matter what
in that moving of the ball.
I know in the political world
that in places like Texas,
a lot of times these conversations,
these hard conversations that
need to be had about policy,
they're not being had except for when we
have these big statewide contest where
we can raise the conversation and the
level of consciousness around them.
And for me that was really important
part of running for office.
Um, but the same can be said of
anything that we are working to do,
anything we're striving for that's hard
and that we may fail at every attempt we
make at it advances that a little bit
and we ultimately will succeed in those
goals,
whether it's me individually or not.
I will have played a part in
moving that ball forward. And,
and so in my essay Wa what I
said was if you're going to fail,
like fail big,
fail gloriously trying to do something
that really matters to you and when you
fail and you deal with that,
um,
consequence in terms of how that feels,
really try to center around
how extraordinary you are
that you tried it and that
you,
you moved to the ball and then if you've
got it in you and I hope you do get
back up and try to do it again. And
let me just, I've got more questions,
but I bet there's probably some stories.
So do we are we didn't live as well.
Yeah.
How do you combat and deal with people
who have violently opposed views to you
even on like base principles and then get
to talking policy with them afterwards
if they're base beliefs are different.
There's some people that you can't
talk to. Um, I know that's not a very,
um, in my leather side of
experience, for example,
I really prided myself on working
across the aisle and got quiet.
A lot of legislation passed doing that.
You have to do that in Texas have it's,
uh, quite, um, predominantly
republican place.
But there are some areas where it's worth
drawing that line. You know, where you,
you can't find a way to compromise.
And I think the most effective way to
communicate when you're in that place or
any of these places actually,
even where you do find that middle is to
do it through personal experiences and,
and human stories.
A lot of times we have these conversations
up in the ethereal world and we're
kind of stuck in our own ideological
way of thinking about them.
But when we can make them more real,
it really makes a difference.
So a great example of how that can move
the ball and the conversation around
Lgbtq equality that really began to
move when a great deal of work was done.
Determining how to talk about it and
to talk about it in a way that was more
resonant than had been the case.
It had been talked about specifically as
equality and that we all ought to care
about it just to be,
you know,
living in a full and equal world that
we all ought to be treated that way.
But the conversation shifted purposefully.
So to be much more personal and a lot
of work actually was done in your state
around that door to door
conversations with people were, had,
were um,
couples who are impacted by the inequality
of marriage equality, for example,
would go to a older
Republican household and say,
we want to talk to you about
why this matters to us.
It really shifted people's thinking
about it and it's because it,
it became personal and because
they saw it as something personal.
Storytelling is powerful.
And I love seeing the fact that it's
becoming more and more prominent and that
technology as has such a great platform
for people to share stories and to
influence based on that.
A lot of abortion story
sharing going on online, um,
post 2013 and the filibuster and kind
of people's consciousness raising about
that. And I think that's our most
effective way to try to get through hard
conversations. But that doesn't
mean everyone's always right.
Hi, I'm Monica and I'm so
excited that you're here.
I grew up in south Texas.
Um,
and when I was growing up and
Richards was the governor,
so I'm going to ask a question
just on the topic of failure again.
Um, she was the first governor I got
to vote for. I went on to work in, um,
President Clinton's first White House,
Barbara Boxer,
Dianne Feinstein.
All these women were,
were running and I felt so invigorated
as a young woman coming out of college.
Um, it's a very different story now and
I look at that from when I was young and
where we are now. Everything that
Hillary Clinton's had to go through.
Everything that Elizabeth Warren
is going through, et Cetera,
everything you've gone through. And thank
you by the way, for going through that.
Um, where have we failed and
what do I tell my daughter?
It's such a hard question. The,
That was such a hard question.
Um, the night of the election,
I have a 34 year old and a 28 year
old daughter and I was at the event in
Manhattan.
I had phone conversations with
both of my daughters that evening.
Both of them crying their eyes out and
both of them asking questions from a
place of what was real fear,
what's going to happen,
what's going to happen.
Um,
I'm feel really optimistic
right now about the,
what's going to happen because I am so
encouraged by the personal reaction that
people have had to saying,
we're going to step forward and
we're going to use our voices.
What you tell your daughter,
I hope is to participate in that with you.
To the extent that you participate in it.
Show her through role modeling the power
that you have and how you're going to
express it and show her that
you're going to sustain it.
I think that's one of the
big questions right now.
Are we going to sustain this enthusiasm
that we have right now for our values
and our desire to make sure that
they're going to be heard? Um,
but at that top level, once
again, I think it is our
very important responsibility to make
sure that we're doing everything we can to
create legislative bodies,
reflect who we are as a community.
Um,
and that doesn't just mean
making sure we have women,
it means making sure we have women
of color who are dramatically
underrepresented and legislative
bodies around this country that we have
transgender,
uh,
representatives that we have people from
different cultures and religions and
backgrounds,
both socioeconomically and otherwise.
Unless we're really reflected
in the decision makers,
we're not going to move things forward
as productively and as effectively and as
quickly as we'd like to see.
So if you're going to spend
your energy somewhere,
I would say run for office, um, or,
or you know, find a candidate that you
can get behind and that you can help,
not just by writing them
a $5 check every week,
but making sure that,
you know,
you're gonna knock on some doors for them
and you have some conversations about
why their election makes a difference.
Republicans for a long time,
I've been very astute at building from
the base up and making sure that they are
putting people in places where they have
the potential to climb in the political
world. So those school board
races and city council races,
which is where I started to, um, it,
it's a really important way
for us to make an impact.
Hi,
my name is Meena and um,
first I just want to say thanks for
coming and also thank you cause I,
you really personally affected me.
Um,
I actually did knock on doors
for you in Texas as part of, um,
um, and I, I really,
I want to say that I feel like
you revitalize politics in Texas.
Um, everyone that I spoke to, we spoke
to a number of people who actually said,
you know, we're switching parties.
Like they were frustrated and,
and I felt like you had a
big part in that thing. Um,
and you know,
as you mentioned,
we are seeing a revitalization in
interest in politics and people getting
involved. Um, one of my questions are,
one of my question is you also see women
voting against their own interests a
lot of the time.
And you know,
I feel like it is because
they just focus on one issue.
How can we make it a larger conversation
so that they actually perhaps want to
start supporting each other rather
than tearing each other down.
Um, I like the way you ended that last
question because it made me think of
something that Chelsea
Handler's had recently about
women that we've been taught
to tackle,
not to climb.
And I do think sometimes we can be each
other's own worst enemy because there's
a lot of judgment that goes on, right?
Depending on the choices that we've made,
our own lives and careers or whether
that career is outside the home or inside
the home.
Um,
this is the $20 million question though.
How do we make sure that people aren't
voting against their own interests?
And there's a lot of education that
needs to take place because people aren't
going to vote against their own interest
because they think they're voting
against their interests. They really
believe they're voting in their interests.
Right? Um, and I,
I think Democrats have failed,
myself included and doing a good job of
communicating why it is that our values
are ones that really are,
are more in alignment with most
peoples in this country. Um,
and there's a lot of work being done
right now on how do we reframe the
narrative and how do we do a
better job of talking about that.
But back to that personal
storytelling again, um,
where we have experiences that we can
share with people who may disagree with us
and paint a picture of a real person
and an impact that would feel more
compelling to them,
where you have opportunities to do that.
I think that's the most powerful
way to cut through that.
And particularly if there's a way to
paint within their own perspective what's
happening to them.
Visa vi a person that they may have
thought was actually aligned with their
interests.
So first of all, I agree
with the optimism. Um,
and I think that's just because
everyone's having such a big wake up call.
So when I came to this country
four years ago from London,
I was maybe a latent feminist.
I mean, I've always believed
in equality, et Cetera,
but it wasn't an issue for me.
And then I came to the balcony where
everyone was male and everyone was working
in tech and everyone was
white. Eh, these issues,
kind of what became more important
for me personally, but now it's like,
it's because it's so bad this Trump,
it feels like the entire kind of middle
ground of people who just didn't care
anymore and didn't seem to
be caring about politics.
I've been awake and so I actually think
this might turn out to be a good thing.
I don't think she hang up. But I
wanted to ask you about this, um,
question about personal storytelling,
which I totally understand. Um,
in terms of building tolerance, right?
Like if you relating to this person, um,
it's different.
And it reminds me when I was 16,
I was in upstate New York as an exchange
student and a family that was, you know,
Aniko blatantly racist,
all these things.
And so my dad would like shout it back,
people out the odd out of this
pickup truck, my host dad and,
but then like Bob, who is the black guy
who worked with him, like somehow didn't,
it wasn't black, right? Cause
he was bald because he knew him.
So I think that's, that's sort of
what you're guessing at is right.
It's like once you,
once you know the person,
you can no longer put them into this
category of otherness. Right? Um,
but on the flip side of the politicians,
it seems like we're moving further and
further away from issues and more and
more about the personality.
And that jump got elected because of his
personality that appeals to TV viewers.
That, and it was nothing about the issues,
right? Everyone ignored all the issues.
So how can we square those things?
Like how can we get,
should we get politics
away from personalities and
more towards issues again?
Or is that just impossible?
I don't,
I don't know if that's possible,
but I think a lot of people to would
tell you that they supported Donald Trump
because they did believe that he was
supportive of policies that we're going to
have a positive impact on their lives.
So whether we were talking about people
who had been impacted by automation,
but he gave an easy target to blame,
which was an immigrant workforce
that had taken your job. Uh,
whether we're talking about people who
worked in industries where environmental
evolution and the protections
of environmental laws had,
um,
decreased the employment capacity in
that particular sector and they'd been
impacted by that. They heard
him speaking to them about that.
Um,
never underestimate the massage
mini that is out there and the,
even if it's not something that people
bring forward consciously their own
subconscious feelings about the threat
that equality in the workforce means to
their own livelihoods and success.
He spoke powerfully to a lot of those
things and people were responding to them.
Um,
but I love your,
your example about Bob Bright because
that's the only way that we can really
counter that.
There was a great story in the New
York Times yesterday about a Mexican
gentleman who was,
um,
detained recently and he's
probably going to be deported.
And in the small Iowa town,
he was so well loved and everyone
was saying, well, yeah, we support,
you know, rounding up and
deporting, but not him. I,
we, I think his name was Carlos.
We'd love Carlos, you know,
and Carlos had done all these
incredible things in the community.
Like supporting firefighters and always
being the person there with the food
drives and different things like that
and you know, everyone loves them.
So making it the reality come to life
for people is really a way to take a step
back and to, to, to look
at things differently.
The real challenge that we have is not
that their personalities and politics
that can be persuasive.
Um,
but that we have a media culture where
people self select the prism through
which they viewed news and they're going
to hear things and be told things very
differently depending on
that self selection. Right.
That to me is the greatest challenge that
we have is cutting through the version
of things that you find on
different news sources and the um,
the decisions or the opinions
that you formed based on,
on what you hear coming from,
from those filters.
And we all owe a responsibility again to
take the power away from their version
and,
and put the power into a reality version
that's based on real human impact is
hard.
But we each have an we're
each and influencer and we
each have an opportunity to
do it to our spheres of influence.
Hi. Um, I'm an immigrant,
a woman and a Latina,
so I 100% relate to your daughter's
fear about what's going on.
Um,
and on top of that,
I like many others that have sort of
like the opposite concern from hers.
I'm raising a white meal
in a Silicon Valley, um,
and I'm deeply concerned about what
he's going to grow up listening to,
um, at school and on,
on the TV and so on. Um,
it was very frustrating not being
able to vote last election. Um,
so I guess my, my question to
you would be how do you think,
um,
we did not get to vote in this country
can have the biggest impact beyond the
ballots and
um, and, and you know, and
myriad of ways and again,
find that thing that feels most
authentic and a value to you personally.
Um,
if it's in the political space,
obviously supporting candidates
and working for them,
even if you can't vote for
them. For example, in Texas,
I had a large number of
dreamers who worked really,
really hard on our campaign.
None of whom could actually vote for me,
but all of whom had a vested stake and
what the outcome of that election looked
like and who cared very deeply about
the direction that we were going.
As a state. You have a wonderful
opportunity with your son, you know,
to be an influencer and the way
he's going to view these issues.
And uh, I, I'm sure he's
going to grow up beautifully,
uh, based on who you are and what your
values are and making sure that you pass
those on to him. Um, if you know,
you find yourself really
deeply passionate about, um,
LGBT equality or the
environment or gender equality,
find an organization that matters to you
and support the work that they do and
ask them how you can be valuable
to the work that they do.
There's so much that's needed in terms
of our time and our passion that as long
as you find a place that
feels meaningful to you,
you will be making a difference.
He really well,
whether you can ultimately vote or not.
And when do,
you were going to take one more question
from a man who's been watching over the
live stream, who asked, how do
you see the role of men as allies?
What can we do to help this?
Cause
that's a really good
question. Um, first of all,
I'll tell you a story about
myself and the word feminism.
Back to what was said earlier,
when I was in my thirties
when I was running for city
council for the first time,
I was asked by a reporter whether I was
a feminist and I answered the question.
No.
And I'm ashamed to tell you that honestly,
but I want to tell you because I want
us to do some self exploration about our
own attitudes and perspectives.
Why did I do that? Well,
I felt like it was categorizing me in
this limited way and defining me in a way
that other people would look
at and disqualify me based
on that categorization.
But by doing that,
I was playing a role
in marginalizing women.
Right? Um, what I would
love to see more of,
and I'm so pleased to see
so much of it right now,
our man stepping forward and saying,
I'm a feminist too,
because to be a feminist really just
means that you support the idea that we
should all be equal in society
and the economy. Right. Um,
what's that bumper sticker feminism is
the radical notion that women are human
beings or something like that.
Um,
I'm really encouraged about that too
though. And where we are, the marches,
the women's marches that took place
around the country, around the world,
there were so many men,
there were so many beautiful,
wonderful man stepping forward and saying,
this matters to all of us.
I'm with her. I'm with her.
Exactly. Um, and you know,
I think more manner or looking at this
from the prism of their mothers and their
sisters and especially their daughters
and wanting to create a world where they
have,
um,
the opportunity to fulfill
their dreams and their,
um, best opportunities for
themselves. And so more and more,
uh,
we're joining this conversation as one.
And I think one of the powerful ways that
we can talk about it is the fact that
when we are all working toward gender
equality were actually all working to a
place where our economy has the
strongest opportunity to thrive.
And it really goes back to looking at
what happened when women were able to
really enter the workforce and stay in
the full time workforce for the first
time.
It was in the 1970s and I know a lot
of the really young people in this room
cannot even fathom,
but and as of 1971 birth
control was illegal.
If you were not married,
you could not have birth control in 1972
with a supreme court decision that's
much less known.
The Roe v Wade,
Eisenstadt v Baird birth control
became legal for unmarried persons,
not just married persons.
There'd been a supreme court decision
a few years prior to that, that equal,
that allowed married people
to access birth control.
So birth control and then of course
Roe v Wade with our right to make
determinations about our own bodies.
We could suddenly decide that we were
going to enter the workforce and we were
going to stay there if we wanted to.
And the women's participation rate in
the workforce took this huge climb.
It went from about the low 20 percentile
to the mid 40 percentile over the
course of the next three
decades and and hung there.
And because it hung there,
we contributed significantly
to the economic output,
the economic growth of the country,
about an estimated one point $7
trillion in 2012 which pays for,
by the way, Medicaid, medicare
and social security combined.
Just our participation,
our increased participation from the
1970s to that point is responsible for
being able to pay for
all of those programs.
So we all have a vested stake and
women's equality and women being able to
realize our full economic
participation in this country.
And I want to hear more women
and men sharing that with,
with their friends and their coworkers
that this isn't just a social issue.
It's not just about saying we ought
to treat everyone fairly and equally,
we all have an economic stake in it.
And it goes back to that saying
that a lot of people think,
is this a try it little campaign saying,
when women do better, we all do better.
It's really true. Um, and so we,
we all have not only a stake in it,
but we ought to be exercising our voices
and making sure that we're spreading
greater understanding about that. Okay.
Well, thank you so much for having me.